-And, finally, this is so cool.
Last night, our pal Aaron Judge
was named the American League's
Most Valuable Player.
[ Cheering and applause ]
And, of course, we wanted to do
something fun to celebrate.
Take a look.
We're at the MLB flagship store
here in New York City
with my pal the
American League MVP Aaron Judge.
We're about to surprise
some baseball fans
who think they're getting
their photo taken
while pretending to pose
in a batter's box
at Yankee Stadium.
[ Laughter ]
Because that's where I see you
all the time --
in the batter's box.
-[ Laughs ]
You ready for this?
-I'm ready for you to be
in the Yankee Stadium
all the time.
That's the only place to see.
-Let's play ball.
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Hello. How you doing?
-This is our photographer,
Chris.
He's going to set you up.
-Okay, so stand
in that batter's box.
I'm going to go over here.
Okay, big smiles.
And 1, 2, 3.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-Strike!
I think that was a strike.
-I think it was a ball.
-You do?
-Yeah.
-Yeah, but can I make the call
on this?
-I think I might do it.
[ Laughs ]
-Alright, 3, 2, 1.
-Here comes the pitch.
-Str-i-i-i-ke!
Strike!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Let's ask Aaron Judge.
-Yeah, I thought I was
a little outside, too.
Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-We're on the same page here.
He's got a good eye.
-No way.
-He's got a good eye.
Yeah.
-[ Laughs ]
-Str-i-i-i-ke
[ Awws ]
3!
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
-That's clearly a ball.
Balls and strikes.
-If Aaron Judge says
that it's a ball,
then Jimmy Fallon says
it's a strike...
-What do you guys think,
ball or strike?
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
-Uh!
That was a strike.
-Ball 4.
-Strike!
-Take your base.
-Aah!
-That was a strike.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
-But who would you --
-[Bleep]
-[ Laughs ]
-One more, you're outta here.
-Jerk --
-You're outta here.
-You're going to throw me
outta here?
-That's it. That's it.
-[ Laughs ]
-How can you throw me
outta here?
-[Indistinct]
-[ Laughs ]
-Aaron Judge.
-3, 2, 1.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
[ Laughter ]
-What?!
-[ Laughs ]
-Hey.
-Jimmy?!
-Yeah.
-What is going on?
-You know Aaron Judge?
-Yeah, like my body's
shaking right now.
-Yeah.
-Sure.
-Okay.
-You want to stand on the box?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Even better.
Even better.
-Well...
[Indistinct]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, my God!
-We saw 60.
-[Indistinct]
-Yes!
-Let's get in the pic, too.
-Oh, my gosh, yeah. What?
-I'm shaking.
[ Camera shutter clicks ]
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-My thanks
to Major League Baseball
and the MLB flagship store.
And, of course, Aaron Judge!
We love you, bud.
Congrats.